hi guys
um i'm kyle then i'm just just an
average
developer programmer um i actually
started with uh angular first
then i found go and then actually found
that they were actually working really
well together
and so i kind of like um i actually
built
i'm actually building an application
right now uh with uh with a partner of
mine
and i thought hey you know um i learned
a lot of great lessons about
using both of them together and also
about the tools around them so i use
vagrant
and and grunt gun just to actually do uh
the builds
and so i thought it would be a kind of a
good a good speech um
and then um but i do want to show the
the actual code so i actually distilled
it down to uh
this little project i called go gongfu
because it's go plus ng equals gong fu
kung fu
right i really like kung fu right um
let's see uh so anyway but but so what i
did was like hey this gongfu
application it could be really simple
it's it's just it has a
uh a user authentication so that you
sign up
and then you basically post a tweet okay
so let's go in here let's see right what
this presentation is about
uh oh and there's a postgres database in
the back too and
this speech is really about creating a
dev environment to work
uh with the front end and the back end
so
um my application kind of works like
this it's like basically a single page
application upfront
angular does a really great job of this
i'm actually handling all the views
so you just you just hand it um objects
right or
you know from a json source then it then
it could just do the rest
so and then i kind of took this
um i said hey you know if you want to
talk to the go server just to send an hr
um
h xhr request either with a get post
patch or delete
i'm going to use those for and then the
server itself then
uh then can be left alone to do what
it's really good with which is
you know persistence and and data and
then actually
some security authentication and secure
cookies
right and the front end can deal with
cool stuff like hey you want to
d3js you know so i i thought it was
really cool
it made sense to me okay
and then we'll take it then we have to
kind of talk about well why do i like
angular
it's just like it's it's not just
angular it's just like basically any
really smart javascript front end that
actually can
can take over and actually do all the
ajax calls and actually
um free free the server from actually
doing
all those templating and all that kind
of junk that's what i think so
anyway but the reason why i like angular
it's uh because
there's two-way data binding so
basically you could write
in your html code little chunks like
this hey uh like
row like ng repeats like and grow
and ch chirps church is an array
of chirp objects which is tricks our
tweets right
then so it automatically knows hey this
this is a repeatable thing
and then it goes hey put each one of
these and that's the
attribute that you're going to use right
um
then in on the javascript side like each
each page or or each um route is going
to have its own controller
and you basically just uh you attach it
to a scope so it knows that hey
it's attached to this html then from
there the controller itself too because
actually has a really cool library
that can actually handle uh xhr request
so you can actually just send that out
to the server and get you get your json
back
all right that's why i like angular okay
so what happens when my project was like
then i suddenly started getting
like all of these uh directories
everywhere you know
um i'm an old java guy so this source
directory
then i could go in there and then
cascades down to
you know all my code models and apis
yada yada and then but i actually
started doing this too because
angular itself has so many different
files that i actually start putting like
this angular stuff in the source in the
source directory
and having the build tool then
concatenate all those out
to the web app directly so the web app
directory is basically
what's finally going to be pushed out
for this client right so
i had all this source stuff that finally
gets
pushed out to the web app directory
correct
i'm actually using exactly uh actually
what i did before was
before i use grunt uh i actually just
wrote a whole bunch of bash scripts
that actually moved it moved it all
around there and did the compile itself
at yada yada but then i found like the
grunt itself is actually a really cool
tool
so um oh one thing i also did too is
like
i do a config jason this thing
is um settings that i have
the grunt file look at i have
the vagrant file the the setup file
installation file
of setting up the database initially it
looks at that
for for the settings and also um
uh the grant looks at it too and
something okay oh
and uh my go app looks at it too
to set it up okay okay let's go here
so the two dev tools i like to use but
i'm highlighting this thing is
vagrant and grunt so vagrant
it's just basically it's just it's just
a shell for uh
for virtualbox virtualbox is the one i
like to use so
um and then grunt is a javascript
container
so it'll concatenate my files it'll run
the test run the go
test unit test then it will actually run
javascript unit tests too a whole bunch
of tests
it will actually build the go executable
itself
yeah right and um bonus top two
uh i found it actually does really great
selenium test which is the mtm test
which is the clicking through the web
browser so
okay so now my app
which i created right it's called i call
it gongfu
and the cool thing about it so so
basically once you log in and create
create an account you just make tweets
and then you can edit your tweets
um and that's basically it that's this
is what
this app does the app
i put it all in my a public repo
so um the great thing about doing this
is like
i could uh everybody actually likes to
look at code better than actually like
uh hear someone else yammer on about
other stuff they don't really care about
so anyway but so you just i post it up
today just go and
grab and fork it whatever it's all there
um
okay so the cool thing about this is i
put the instructions on there so
maybe i don't have to go through the
instructions in this speech i could just
kind of more just talk about like
um how i actually develop in it and
actually use this environment
and then if you're curious about it then
you can actually go back and say okay
hey
what are the steps you know and then
what are the configuration files to
actually
configure it right yada yada yada
go packages okay
why did they fit well together uh well
the architect actually allows me to to
have any any kind of back end so you
could choose
you could have whatever front end you
want and whatever back end you want
i actually wrote a um an application a
test application
a long time ago where i had my front
angular front end talked to two
different backends
one was ruby and the other one was go so
uh but it's just my own personal
preference i let go
um there there are other things like
which i start to notice
how the go language and javascript
language are very similar
and and and actually um
i like go just because in this
architecture right
the front end just sends back a payload
of adjacent
adjacent object right then the go can
actually just unmarshal that right away
and then here and this throws throws
into a struct
so for me it's really seems it's really
seamless seamless but it's actually just
it's really efficient i like it so
that's the reason that's my short reason
for it jason's just going back and forth
between the two
that's correct okay yeah that's correct
and actually i could show you an example
of that too but uh
um but generally see what i would do is
like
here let's see control let's see okay
from from from my machine i would
basically just
run my instance here by doing vagrant up
okay it was already running okay then i
just ssh into it
ssh okay
oh and the cool thing like the reason
why i like to use vagrant is because i
like to develop
in the exact os that it's going to be
finally
be running in you know it's uh um i'll
do some stuff on my mac
natively just if it's trivial but if
it's something but also if it's
something that actually has a database
and you actually start you know um
uh you need to start dumping the
database all the time so i'd rather just
have it in its own
nice box and then i could shut it down
and the other reason why i like to have
virtualbox is because um
uh i'm a consultant so i have different
different projects going on the same
time
and i have one computer so i can just
switch between the two okay
so here okay and the cool thing about
this too is like um
in vagrant there's actually a sim link
back up to your host machine so i
actually did the sim link for code
so if i go into the code directory is
actually
the host directory up here so it's the
same directory
so so so which means like for my
version control it's just if i'm if i'm
building and
changing that the instance on there it
gets gets sent back to the virtual
control
okay so here okay um
let's see what i want to do okay here
i'll show you this one example first
let's see
okay i'm gonna run my gong here let's
build it first right
so i just go like grunt is the tool so i
just use grunt and dev
the cool thing about this is it it
actually uh you're concatenating all my
files
first then it runs oh the other good
thing is
uh go compiles fast that's the thing i
like about it
but it went through and actually did all
the tests too so if you actually go back
over here
to my sorry
here oh let's just do this
right here okay
see the see there's a there's there's a
this is actually done by the test right
there that uh
every single time i hear if i did this
again control c
and i build it again that task i have it
built
and then actually run run the uh run the
web server right away
so there we go so there's actually a
third one now because
the testing actually did that um what i
can also do here too is like
i can run that selenium test i was
talking about so from here i can go
grunt localhost
and let's see this will actually fire up
like um
we got this select you know
the web browser selenium test and it
just runs it and then
here you can see it
it's uh it did this because because i
haven't that's
the selenium test just creates a token
and the tokens one these numbers and
just doesn't bother me now
um let's see what else can uh
okay okay the reason why i liked
ollie grunt is just because it's it's
just from here like you can
you can actually you know it's it's just
easy just to do iterations like here i
i'll change some
some code but it compiles everything it
compiles the front end and the back end
so you're always getting the latest
stuff like you know so it's not
pieced out it's uh okay uh let's see
what else he can show you
okay oh you know what i can show you if
i can show you this
okay if we look at the network traffic
here here let's okay here let's let's
let's go do a new one here hello
hello
you can see that right here it's uh
all it does is just oh it's sorry it's
really down there
all it does is just does um an
extra request up here to to this url
with with a certain method this this
one's post because it's a brand new one
then there's just another one that comes
back and this is the the whole set
this is all the tricks but also if i
were to go and edit this guy
like bought right here and it changes to
fred
save changes then there's another chirp
right
there's another request right here this
one's a patch instead
and the patch
contains the um json object
and and then that's it so
here but i can show you a little bit of
the code of like how how from here
what happens when here then it goes to
the the go server
okay let's go uh
see okay
oh actually let me back up a second here
you have to go
here
this is the app server and
basically i use this one uh
this one framework called um gentonic
i like i like it it works it works
really well because it creates a really
clean
route table right here here's my main so
you basically
have one gen object here then it goes to
routes here
so but i specified here if you go to the
slash api
you can actually see like hey if you use
a delete sort this address
it goes to goes to the that function
right here
that's it's just really clean so what we
did was we did a patch for chirp so
which means in vi
chirp patch chirp and then
i do it this way i use the source obi
thing up there
let's see so we can go this way
source the reason why i do this
structure is because i'm an old java guy
and this is how it was done
so
and then you look for your function it's
just
it's a was a patch right patch chirp
here we go it says
you read the context i have a model of a
chirp
i read in the body and then
right here here and it does the
unmarshing right here and say hey just
just put it to my uh it's my trip object
and then after okay
then the query statement for the update
okay then it says hey go update it
okay and then all these are if it fails
and then it just just throws back a nice
json
message say hey it fell so that's how
you want your
error handling in this architecture it's
kind of nice actually
just send it back sorry i couldn't do
anything for you
and then if everything's okay then you
send a payload back
what i do is i just send back a little
json message and say hey updated this
and then i gave the idea what it
what it updated um this statement here
you want to look at this statement
i attached it to uh my model
okay
okay sure
and then what was it uh it was update
right statement update right here
okay and here's one here's also another
cool thing that
you can kind of see right here an api i
have my
chirp test these all the tests and these
all
ran every single time i do like a
compile and it's kind of nice i i just
do grunt dev it compiles this it runs a
test every single time
so i know if i make any changes to it
and in my code then
then it's it's always been constant
tested so
um i have a really unstructured speech
from for now so i actually um
uh i'll open it for questions and well
if you can just talk a little bit more
about your overall architecture you've
got a postgres database
oh okay you got uh essentially a net
http
package and then you've got much
of it yes yes
um so oh here we go
what's that what's being stored in
postgres
um the tweets and the users okay yeah so
it's it's it's basically here it's
basically uh
i kind of have it what i didn't do just
um
just for my project is because i i
didn't try to find an orm just yet
i actually wanted to learn you know as
natively as possible like you know the
go like you know how do you do database
um you know how to work with the
database so basically for me
um
look at the models here it's just oh
actually here i can show you actually
actually
this is in my devops right
i have an sql here's a create table
so um this is what's stored in the
database this is it
and what i can actually do from um from
grunt too this is actually kind of nice
i can do from grunt i can
skip out here i can do like a grunt pg
rebuild
and this would actually rebuild oh i
have to do the password
okay
okay there we go and if you guys should
go back to the
oh you have to run it again soon can't
steer
oh there you go
okay um
one came in uh with my initial build
yeah that like that's in the booth and
this one came in with the test
just because i i re-ran the test um
yeah so so basically it's um
uh maybe i should talk about grunt a
little bit right because since i'm using
that a lot um
see um grunt is just a com
it's just a it's just a package full of
these node.js
packages so um when i found out that
that node.js can actually just run bash
scripts that was
pretty much all i needed right so but
but there are a few i i did use i
actually use this one go package
there actually is a no go package
builder the cool thing about it
lets you um it lets you set more than
one go path
so i found that was nice and then you
just kind of set some different settings
oh and i take the settings from my
config.json
so um
but even for all the database stuff
i actually just run shell so i'm so used
to actually uh
uh running postgresql or or
psql commands from the command line that
you could just put it inside
okay yeah like these are just bash
commands but i just put it inside
grunts so you can actually just have it
all together so it's just a matter of
organizing
i found that this technique works for me
so
okay yes
how's that what selenium
how am i using it okay sure um obviously
it's a great tool i would actually use
the go driver
but i'm just wondering which are you
writing your tests in javascript
i'm writing my test in javascript um
oh oh yeah you know what uh i have tried
the go selenium
um package that somebody wrote out there
and
um i didn't get very far with it so but
the cool thing about this i could but
but this selenium package which is
actually written for
uh angular it's called a projector and
actually because actually has
it has it has the um selenium
uh drivers in there too but it also has
drivers additionally for
for uh for angular it's just just so
that you can actually even
specify hey select me this ng um
what do you call it uh this ng model
then it actually knows that so so so so
just basically like shortcuts on top of
that
yeah um
once i figure out this okay uh was there
any difference between the uh
the selenium cylinder drivers and and
this one i actually prefer
oh my my preference on the selenium
drivers is this
uh is this java javascript
driver um i was able to get it up pretty
fast
and it's actually it's just oh and plus
it fits in this
um this grunt tool because the grunt
tool is actually just a javascript tool
so so if so so it fit really well yeah
that's what i prefer
um any other questions or all right
how are you serializing or are you
transforming
go has marshalling and it's it's just
the standard um
jason library in there are you getting
back jason
no i'm getting uh yes exactly i'm
getting a row back from
from postgresql
or something or how are you getting that
are you going to date
yeah yeah yeah exactly here yeah okay
yeah
uh
okay like in chirp right here um
let's see if i do a select let's see
it's
oh no no okay no no no no it's it's hang
up here
so here like like uh
it's there's um yes there's a
there's a scan uh method
from the uh uh query
from uh from the query library which
allows you to actually
send it back to that structure that's
struck
so um let me see if i'm part of the
driver
yes i think that's a standard go go uh
database driver yes okay
yeah the one i use is young and second
up here it's just it's a standard one
was uh
yeah was it
yeah it's down there okay yeah it's it's
it's yeah like it was in there
so so the scan function of the driver
will automatically turn your post
into chase go up a couple lines okay go
ahead
yeah and i think it has to be ordered in
the same order that you actually have
ordering your struct
yeah uh i was i was going to try to look
for an orm that you know that was a
little bit more intelligent
but then i had a whole bunch of stuff to
do and actually and actually i wanted to
learn it
this technique first and then go on to
an orm after that
hi we found a package called sequel
struck the other day that uh
okay that's the tedious part of scanning
the matching model oh right right okay
right okay okay cool okay cool
yeah i just can't hear the rest of the
query
i'm sorry why did you put most of the
sequel in the mother within the sky
in here um
well i guess in here i guess and here's
the logic
and then in the model itself it's like
uh like i thought of the query
the query string is just something that
belonged in the model because it's
it's it's attached to it and it won't
you know what i mean i
you could put it in different places but
yeah i thought i thought it was
it made sense to me yeah
guys hey um anyway thanks thanks a lot
for listening to me and um
uh if you're interested in the code it's
it's just uh
uh it's on the web i mean it's it's on
github
and then uh if you have any comments
about it or reminding me uh
just send me an email